Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas we
have now learned has been for years
claiming income from a company that did
not actually exist when he said he
earned income from that company now is
this simply a paperwork mistake or an
innocent mix-up or is it the latest in
multiple new chapters of the questions
surrounding Clarence Thomas we are going
to discuss all of it now you may be
saying David I just heard something
about Clarence Thomas a week and a half
ago before you left you told us about
Clarence Thomas's Financial relationship
with a billionaire vacations Yachts all
sorts of different things and yes that
is indeed true but there are now
multiple new allegations against
Clarence Thomas so let's jump into the
first one this is from a Washington Post
investigation which says Clarence Thomas
has for years claimed income from a
defunct real estate firm
the misstatements which began when a
family business transferred its Holdings
to another company are part of a pattern
that has raised questions about how the
Supreme Court Justice views his
obligation to accurately report details
about his finances to the public the
details are actually relatively
straightforward here over the last two
decades Clarence Thomas has reported on
financial disclosure forms that his
family was receiving rental income to
the tune of hundreds of thousands of
dollars from a company called ginger
limited partnership that company which
is a Nebraska Real Estate firm launched
in the 1980s has not existed since 2006
okay that's 17 years that this company
has not existed that company was shut
down and a separate firm was created the
similarly named firm assumed control of
the shuttered company but Clarence
Thomas keeps reporting that he's making
between fifty and a hundred thousand
dollars a year from that company there
is no mention of the actual company that
exists Ginger Holdings LLC now could
this just be an innocent paperwork error
well the article addresses that it says
the previously unreported misstatement
might be dismissed as a paperwork error
but it is among a series of errors and
omissions that Thomas has made on these
forms over the last many decades and if
you take them all together there are a
number of red flags here now this is not
the only
new controversy involving Clarence
Thomas the Grio reports Thomas sold real
estate to a donor and didn't report that
he did that this is this is yet another
one of these oh it's a mistake which
just by coincidence makes it seem as
though Thomas has has fewer Financial
entanglements with donors and influence
Peddlers the Grio reports the 2014 real
estate deal
shines a new light on Thomas's
decades-old relationship with Harlan
Crowe that is the real estate magnate
and financier for conservative claw
causes who I told you about a week and a
half ago and indeed Harlan Crowe bought
properties three properties belonging to
Clarence Thomas and his family in a
transaction worth more than a hundred
thousand dollars that Thomas did not
ever report so listen Clarence Thomas
should resign the totality of the
financial picture here is an absolute
nightmare over the weekend I read about
something called The Abe Fortis
president Fortis is spelled
f-o-r-t-a-s Abe Fortis was a Supreme
Court Justice appointed by LBJ in 1965.
he was nominated by LBJ to Chief Justice
in 68 but that nomination was eventually
withdrawn because of controversy related
to his financial dealings and the Fortis
president precedent refers to this kind
of tradition that has emerged since his
nomination was withdrawn which suggests
Supreme Court nominees who have been the
subject of significant controversy or
opposition during their confirmation
process may not be successful in their
bid for appointment to the court so in
other words the idea is if a supreme
court nominee becomes too controversial
they
um ultimately are not going to succeed
and it's been cited a whole bunch of
different times it came up with Brett
Kavanaugh we know Brett Kavanaugh
ultimately did become Supreme Court
Justice Etc and the idea here is it's
time to go it's time to get out now
whether this actually is going to come
to force when it comes to Clarence
Thomas
is is unclear but the argument that's
being made is this all actually goes
back to Clarence Thomas's start on the
court it goes back to those hearings
where Clarence Thomas was accused of
sexual harassment
and we should have known at the time
that he was unfit to serve on the court
that in a way telegraphed or predicted
what ultimately is coming to pass with
Clarence Thomas which is a sort of
20-year record of endless forms of
financial impropriety questions which
ultimately are going to force him off
the court now do I believe Clarence
Thomas is actually going to be forced
off of the court I really don't
I really don't and one of the things
that we have seen is that while on paper
there are all sorts of different rules
and conventions and stipulations and
laws
when they are actually challenged just
because a check or balance is there
in writing does not mean it will
actually be enforced we've seen so many
Hatch Act violations during the Trump
Administration kellyanne Conway and
others it all went nowhere we've seen
all sorts of violations of the way
presidents are supposed to comport
themselves during the Trump
Administration and at least for the most
part there have been no consequences so
do I believe that Thomas should resign
of course
do I believe that Clarence Thomas has
violated those judicial canons which say
that judges and justices should avoid
not only actual impropriety but even the
appearance of impropriety of course
that's been violated by Clarence Thomas
but do I believe he will actually be
held accountable for it I don't if you
do
I want to hear from you because if
anything we've learned over the last six
years that unless we really have a
system not only willing to have checks
and balances but to actually enforce
them and hold people accountable for
them nothing happens and that's been the
greatest lesson of the last six years
for me